hey guys this is andrew from
trainingsenses.com i've been working as
a professional trainer for the past six
years in hong kong
and right now i'm doing youtube video
for around three months
because i wanna pass the knowledge guys
and i wanna show you
actually how we work as pro traders so
if you're interested to know all the
different tools and techniques that we
can use to make money on the markets
you are in the right place so today i
want to make an
update on tesla because a lot of things
happen in the past few days
so let's get into it
[Music]
so first thing let's do a bit of
technical analysis because this is the
reason
i'm on youtube i love technical analysis
i'm using it every day
at work to actually set up my trades
because it gives you so much information
when you know how to use it so
as i always say technical analysis is
about probabilities and expected gains
you don't know you just can try to guess
and associate the right amount of money
that you think depending on the
probability of your trade and your risk
reward ratio
this is what we do guys this is how
traders are working
so here let's do a bit of long-term
analysis
so i'll use illiot wave principle so you
know
moves up developing five waves and i try
to identify five waves here
and here i can see one two three four
five
quite obvious you know this is the
impulse affiliate wave principle for
those who interested to know more about
idiot
wave theory please click on the link in
the description of this video and you're
gonna
receive a free video that i just
finished and you're gonna learn about
the impulse and of course i'm gonna
discuss
the other patterns as well in the other
videos usually in an impulse the second
wave is the zigzag so one two three
and the the fourth wave if the second
wave is zigzag the fourth wave is the
flat
so this is a flat correction you see
because it's flat and the zigzag is like
this
so right now this is showing me that
probably i am right
about my counting because it fits well
so i'm pretty sure we're gonna have this
fifth wave but actually we already had
it so the question is is it finished or
not
to me the fifth wave should have gone to
1030
it only went to 900 something so
it doesn't look to me like it's finished
so on the long term i'm bullish
now uh if we go on the shorter term guys
some bad stuff happen very bad stuff so
i was very bullish in the video
i did last week a few days ago because
we had the 200 period moving average
that was coming here and we had
this bull flag that was uh drawing here
and i was seeing here
a nice channel in which we were so i was
saying probably 750 is gonna be
the uh support level that is gonna act
as
a bouncing level and it got broken guys
broken and very sadly we lost 16
which is really a lot for a big cap like
tesla
so here people were asking me should i
buy the deep you know
i was saying that 660 680 is the next
support level
uh how i found it guys just by you know
checking here
here you know the most recent these the
better it is so the first
reaction that i see so you have one here
of course so this is almost where we
we gone but here you have one as well
the previous support level was here and
it was resistance here
so this one looks good to me so it's
around 660 650
so i was saying that this is going to
probably be the support level so people
who ask me should i buy the dip i said
be careful buy this dip if you want
because we have not retested 750 yet
so of course usually when you have a
downward
trend that is setting up we usually have
a retest
of the breakout level which was here
750.
so if you bought this deep congrats well
done you need to have solid nerves
when uh the the market is crashing like
this if you did it well done
but careful guys right now because we
are retesting 750 the 200 moving average
is right now at 760.
so we have the 20 period moving average
into 20
on a four hours time frame 20 per moving
average that is at 750 as well so
basically all the moving averages are
gonna
converge here within a few days so this
area you're gonna have a lot of
resistance so i would not said set up
some buddhist trade at this
level here it's a good level to actually
exit guys on the short term
right and then if you wanna enter back
this trade
so to me this is bearish on the short
term but like i said i'm bullish on the
long term
so we are just trying to find where is
the next
good level to buy and to me as i said in
the comments of my previous video
this level is here you need to go on a
longer time frame and we are trying to
find
so it's here guys actually it's the
maximum level that i had here and this
is to me the next strong support level
so if we go to this level
the discount and the probability for
bounce back makes it a very nice level
to play
all this area is for me a no man's land
alright so i would not take any trade in
this
area here i would be bearish on the very
short term
and i would use a stop loss here so if
so the stop loss can be used if you want
to take a short position it can also be
used
uh if you want to enter a long position
guys you know i like to uh actually go
with the trends so when these trends
start to be
to revert and to be bullish if we see
the market going above
so the first is the downward sloping
trend line of my channel
here so which is at 750 if we go above
750
then we go above the 200 moving average
that is at 260
and then you see this trend line guys
one two
three reactions and then we go above
this trendline so 765
probably in a few days 760. we have a
breakout
then i would buy the re-test and i would
buy 7.50 so i need
to wait at least one week to have like
you know the price action doing
something like this
bam bam here there's gonna for sure be
some resistance then
break out you don't buy it you wait if
you miss it you miss it guys i'm sorry
but like you can't
buy it to break out too high and then
you wait for the retest and then you buy
it all right and then you're gonna have
something like this
and we're gonna finally maybe go there
so this is the bullish case the bearish
case is
to me the most likely one right now but
once again guys it's all about
probabilities all right
so if you trade with a tight stop loss
and you're wrong it's fine you're not
losing too much money and you can go to
the next trade
but here the bearish cases we do
something like this and then
we go here we break out we break this
one we have this consolidation and then
we go higher so this is the bearish case
and once again guys i like to use
trend lines as you saw and here you can
see
the whole move up guys is was actually
you know
in a nice trend so
if you connect this low and the slow
guys what is it
giving to you it was the support i'm
gonna put it in red
because now it's a resistance and this
resistance
was actually guys at this level so
that's why 750 was a very strong support
we you had
all those indicators that would
converging here
and we broke it so this is a very strong
signal and
the bears and control guys here the
bears and control
once again it might shift again i don't
know the market looks like
it's bullish it wants to revert and to
come back i'm talking about the snp
about the bitcoin everything you know
it's a biodeep
uh mode so maybe we're gonna just buy
the dip and this would be a fake
breakout i don't know but for now we're
having a clear breakout
so the most likely scenario once again
when you see that we broke this trend is
that we correct it
this is the most likely scenario and
correcting something like this
is actually this is not really a
correction level especially
that's short in time a real correction
needs to last a bit longer
and to go a bit lower so this would be a
correction
so this is a scenario that would make
sense but so if it happens guys
i mean you know it's a beautiful
opportunity you can buy at 5 30 right
the maximum level we had here that was
support here as well
and this would look like actually this
move up
is finished we did we did the second one
and we are starting maybe a new bull
trend we're gonna analyze things when
they arrive
so that's it for me guys i hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything new and stay close to show